every Milestone that Mr Beast would hit
he talks how he got more and more lonely
you have someone who is breaking records
using the word loneliness when you think
they would attract more friends what
would you say to that there's a verse in
the Book of Ecclesiastes that says the
man who fears God avoids all extremes
mind you this is written by somebody who
was a lot bigger than Mr Beast King
Solomon is the wealthiest man who ever
lived and he got to this place of things
are meaningless I think that Obsession
out of control will lead you to a bad
place and the path he's on the amount of
Fame accolades money that's enough to
mess up anybody's Soul other people do
say that it's Lonely at the Top but I
think that if it's Lonely at the Top for
you you did it wrong